alexandria ocasio-cortez was on abc this
weekend
and um made some rather dubious claims
about the capitol hill riots and the the
uh the danger that she says she was in
let's let's take a listen to this
republican members of congress who
opposed
uh raising objections to the certifying
the electoral college vote have written
a letter
to president-elect biden opposing
impeachment here's what the letter says
it says in the spirit of healing
and fidelity to our constitution we ask
you fully request that speaker nancy
pelosi discontinued her efforts to
impeach
president donald j trump a second time a
second impeachment only days before
president trump leave office
is as unnecessary as it is inflammatory
they're saying for the sake of unity
for go impeachment
well you know i think there's a couple
of things one is we have to understand
that what happened on wednesday
was insurrection against the united
states
that is what that is what donald j trump
engaged in and that is what those who
stormed the capital
engaged in and so when we talk about
healing the process of healing
is separate and in fact requires
accountability
and so if we allow insurrection against
the united states
with impunity with no accountability we
are
inviting it to happen again that is how
serious it is and i do not believe
that that perhaps my colleagues weren't
in that room
perhaps my colleagues were not
fully present for the events on
wednesday but
half of we came close to half of the
house nearly dying
on wednesday oh you did half of the
house nearly dying
half really that's what we came close to
and she has no the phoniness here of
course is off the charts
across the board with everything she
said um and the idea that that
half of the house almost died is is she
has no basis for saying that but
then again this is the one to remember
if you're if you're you shouldn't be
surprised to see drama and hyperbole
from alexandria cortez
this is the woman who went down to the
border and if you remember a couple
years ago
took took pictures of herself pretending
to cry
outside of a uh immigrant detention
center actually she wasn't even outside
of the detention center she was outside
of a parking lot
she took pictures of herself outside of
an empty parking lot posing as if she
was in tears
so keep that in mind that's that's who
this is coming from
but everything else about this was
insurrection insurrection
even if it was okay uh i'm not even
arguing about
what label we we put on it whether it
was or wasn't
i don't believe for a second that
alexandria case or cortez or any of the
other democrats actually care about
insurrection
in principle because they certainly
didn't care
but leftist radicals set up
their own country in the middle of a of
an american city
for months and were allowed to do it
and we all just went about our day and
said okay well that's something you can
do now apparently
they set up their own sovereign country
said they were seceding from the union
had their own country in the middle of
the city is that that insurrection
or as i pointed out many times last week
invading a police station and burning it
to the ground
it's a government building that's an
attack on law enforcement
is that insurrection she didn't care
about that
and speaking of pretending to care about
things
it has it has it's very difficult for me
to hear
people like this um or democrats
generally as they have been in the media
um over the last several days has
pretended has
been pretending to mourn the death of
officer sicknick who's uh
the officer who who died during the uh
during the capitol hill riot now
i mourn for for the officer and for his
family
and i'm devastated that he died i'm
infuriated by
by his loss it's also it's also not yet
clear
it's not exactly clear yet how he died
there's a lot of information we haven't
been given
and as far as i know the the the images
of of his interactions with the crowd
whatever happened at that incident we
haven't seen any image of we haven't
seen any video we haven't seen any
photograph as far as i know and i've
looked
um maybe there isn't any image but that
would be hard to believe these days
so it's not exactly clear what happened
but or how it happened they haven't
given us all the information yet
but however it happened it's a terrible
tragedy because we know that an officer
died
yet now you have democrats in the media
talking about officer siknik and how
terrible it is and what a tragedy it is
and it is terrible it is a tragedy
i just don't believe that they give the
slightest
damn about him and the reason for that
is that this is the only dead cop
that these people have ever mourned ever
prove me wrong find me another example
because there unfortunately have been a
lot of dead police officers
through through history and especially
this past year
a lot of police officers were physically
assaulted police officers were
beat over the head with bricks during
blm riots
we got we got video in new york police
officer getting beat over the head with
a brick
the only reason he didn't die he didn't
die thank god it's not for lack of
trying though
we don't give blm credit because well
they tried to kill a bunch of cops but
they failed
you know your credit for that it's it is
it is
the rest of society's great fortune that
he's still alive but you tried to kill
him but anyway do you remember
did alexandria did any democrat when
that video came out in new york
of the cop getting beat over the head
with a brick how many democrats how many
people in the media condemned it
did any of them
so i don't believe it they don't really
care
you know pretending to be upset that uh
the the flag wasn't put at half-mast
outside the white house right away
once again i think the flag should be at
half-mast and now it is i think it
should have been a half-mast right away
do they actually give a damn though
about that
no they don't absolutely full of it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated